hello everyone this game was played in a
very strong international tournament it
was the civics tournament in 1959 and
well ten of the strongest grandmasters
in the world were invited to play a
tournament along with six six local
players and this included the Swiss
national champion mr. dieter Keller and
this is game
Mikell towel versus the dieter Keller
this is Round seven of the tournament
and well it was a it was a very close
tournament Michael towel actually
thought that this was this was gonna be
a breeze for him as he didn't consider
the tournament to be that strong because
you know this is 1959 towel is in
amazing shape this is one year before
Tao defeats both Munich for the world
championship title and well toluse
actually loses his game in round one
against the Swiss player and he draws
against Fischer I think it was in round
2 and well then towel gets back into
shape and then again loses against
Seto's alliteration round nine and it
was a it was actually a very close
battle between toweling licorice all the
way to the final round of the tournament
but actually it was mr. dieter Keller
that defeated Bobby Fischer in the final
round if if Fischer won his final game a
Fisher would tie with Michael towel for
the first place in this tournament but
as mr. dieter Keller defeated Bobby
Fischer Michael Tao got 1st place with
11 and a half points set azar glue each
was second with 11 points and Bobby
Fischer shared a third place with Paul
Karras with 10 and a half points so
let's see this game it's a quite an
amazing game played by mikhail tal and
well it's a pretty standard style game
you know towel complicates and then his
opponent has to cough lift a lot he gets
into time trouble and then towel
prevails
so we have Knight to f3 by towel and
Knight to f6 by mr. dieter Keller c4 we
have e 6 9 2 C 3 and d5 we have D 4 so
this is the Queens gambit declined
c6 so the semi Slav Bishop to g5 and now
D captures on c5
we have it for the the bottom unique
variation a very sharp line dieter goes
for b5 and we have a four tall doesn't
go for a5 the sharpest variation he
decides to go for a4 and we have Queen
to b6 so here we have a Bishop captures
on f6g captures on f6 and here tau plays
Bishop to e2 and okay
well it's black smooth and well it's
interesting black plays a six here but
why not
pawn to b4 this is a very nice well a
very nice pawn push as it will force
this night to go back the problem is
that after b4 tall has this move a5 and
after the Queen moves he has Knight to
a4 and well whatever black plays here
this is this is better for white for
example even if he captures the pawn
simply Bishop captures on c4 and white
is better here so after Bishop to e2
dieter decided to play a six tall
castles and we have Bishop to b7 and
okay Talos King is safely put on g1 and
the deters King is still on eh so you
don't have to guess twice what towel
plays here
of course he plays d5 he wants to open
up the center and the start Cup
complicating things I will have C
capture son d5e captors on d5 and now
dieter pushes before he wants to get rid
of this night before capturing the pawn
on d5 but now it all has the same idea
as before people is a 5 we have Queen to
c7 and now top plays D captures on e6 he
sacrifices this knight on c3 and the
wall this I mean best move here is
actually to capture the night so he does
he captures be captures on c3 and
topless night to d4
we have worked the g8 now dieter plays
rook the g8 and up his threatening rook
captures and g2 or Bishop captures and
g2 depends depends on what topless
topless Queen to a fort with Czech and
how does the how does black play here
well obviously he can't block it with a
knight this point is covering this
seven he can move the King but can he
play a bishop the c6 this is an
interesting variation and I mean this is
a very interesting variation if he plays
Bishop to c6 top plays he captures on f7
would check now for King the king and
the rook
so after King captures on f7 towel has a
queen to c4
now with check and well if black doesn't
want to lose the rook he has to go King
to g7 and he well I mean he doesn't have
to but not all has nice to e6 of working
the king and the Queen but after this
Queen to c4 he decides to give up the
rook and plays for example King to e8
well this is well he gets the bishop to
h5 with check and what do you play here
well rope to g6 comes to mind
so after rook to e1 check we have king
to d8 and not simply capturing this rook
with H capture for example this would be
okay and rook to d1 and the wall this is
this is terrible to play for black white
is completely winning here so what drew
the screen to a4 check by tile a dieter
actually decided he doesn't want to give
tall any chances here and he plays the
King to d8 which is actually the best
move towel plays g3 now defending this
g2 born as tall claims that he does have
time for this and we have Bishop to d5
although in this position actually see
captures on b2 would have been the best
move but you know tallies coming for you
you don't want to you don't want to grab
another point so he plays Bishop to d5
now adding protection here and also
attacking this e six points so if if
pawn captures an f7
even Bishop captures on f7 is possible
tacos rook F 2 d1 now lining that rook
up with the king we have king to c8
getting out of the way and now tall
plays B captures on c3 town knows that
this C captures on b2 was a nasty move
by him by black so he plays it himself
and also he opens up this this line for
the rook so we have Bishop to c5 now
attacking the knight and well what do
you play here is white I mean there are
a lot of options here the engine move
the end remove its Bishop captures on c4
here grabbing a pawn but you know towel
always has a towel move somewhere
already so in this position tal played
East 7 and it's very interesting what's
the idea behind this East 7 move well ok
obviously the idea is eh Queen so we
have Knight to c6 this night now blocks
this Queen so coverage of the e8 Square
and here topless Bishop to g4 chick and
what's the idea well of course the
bishop cannot be captured as now upon to
e8 Queen it is possible so after Bishop
to g4 check we have a king to b7 and now
a move that comes to mind is definitely
rook a to be one trick but tal has an
even better idea table is 9th to b5 now
with an attack on the Queen and well can
denied we captured let's check if a
capture some b5 we have a queen capture
somebody if I would check and this comes
with an attack on this Bishop here so
this Bishop should probably block Bishop
to b6 maybe and I were to capture 75 and
well white is destroying black here this
is completely winning black is losing
another piece this rook to d7 idea is
here black can't defend this
so after night to b5 dieter decided to
go for Queen to e5 and well what the
stop play here here top plays rook to e1
attacking the Queen we have a Bishop to
e4 now blocking and now towel gets the
other broke into the game because now
this Bishop covering b1 isn't really
important since the bishop cannot
captured work as capture screen and we
have rook captures and g4 here by Keller
as now now killer claims that this
bishop can indeed be captured but top
plays rook captures on e4 and well this
is a this is a very critical moment of
the game the killer has to decide
whether to capture the rook would the
rook or with the Queen interestingly
killer decided to play rook Queen
captures on e4 and this allows Knight to
d6 forking the king and the Queen but
it's a very very interesting line if
rook captures on e4 if rook captures on
e4 you get night to d4 check and well if
you capture the night for example I mean
you can't capture the night now because
it's a check from the rook but you do
have to cover up so after a move like
nice to be for because Queen captures on
c6 was a threat you get rook capture
some before Bishop capture some before
and Queen to d7 with check for example
Queen to c7 and now you get a Queen to
d5 with check King to b8 and now you
grab this rook on e4 and well this is
the problem this Bishop is still
attacked here on before and also the
tallest threatening eh with Queen so
only move is probably Bishop captures
here on e7 and now Knight to c6 with
check King cc8 Knight captures on e7
with the check King goes back Knight to
c6 with check King to b7 and night to
before with check came to b8 and the
Queen to d5 and well although black is
up the exchange black doesn't really
have a move here this would be this no
this would be winning for white
especially especially in time trouble
because if black ever plays rook the
rook to a7 simply Knight to c6 wins the
rook and well white pawn structure is
somewhat better more white is better
here so but although this was a very
long line to calculate and the color
probably didn't do manages to do to time
trouble
so after this rook captures on e4 our
killer played a queen captures only for
allowing Knight to d6 with the check we
have Knight to d6 check King to c7 and
now Knight grabs Queen on e4
rock captures night and now Queen to d1
and well this is this is probably this
is this is the last moment that Keller
could have could have played for for a
draw or even for a better game the point
is this pawn on e7 has to be captured
either by rook characters or by Bishop
captures white Keller didn't play this I
have really have no idea
simply the rook captures on e7 seems
perfectly fine and even after move like
Queen to d5 this does attack the bishop
and also I don't know Bishop to e7 and
what what does white play here this this
seems completely okay okay Queen
captures on c4 maybe but I it seems like
black can hold this white is better but
it's not clear but after this Queen to
d1 move Keller played rook to e5 I have
no idea why he played rook to e5 maybe
to prevent Queen d5 for some reason but
here targets targets the killing move
he has rook to b7 with check and well
what are you gonna play here you really
have no other choice than to capture the
rook
so King captures rook can be seven and
well if you look at this killer has four
pieces for the Queen but this is a very
temporary Queen to d7 with check and the
King has only one square to go to King's
to b8 we have eh Queen rook captures
Queen Queen captures rook honey it would
check and well the King has to go to be
seven because this Knight is attacked so
only King to be seven guards both the
rook and the night Queen to d7 check we
have King to be eight and now Queen
captures on c6 and in this position mr.
dietrick eller resigned the game as now
only rook and Bishop cannot cannot
counter the Queen so yeah a very very
interesting game by mikhail tal and well
he did the defeat the had the swiss
national champion who who was actually
responsible for for mikhail tal winning
first place as he
he took one whole for one whole point
from Bobby Fischer so yeah definitely a
nice game and definitely another victim
of Dallas trickery so yeah I would like
to think that David Hammond mr. Norton
Devi K for a contribution to my channel
thank you a lot I appreciate it and yeah
as usual you can check to my previous
videos here thank you all for watching I
will see you soon